[Music]
as i mentioned i'm alexander rose the
executive director here at long now and
um
i am a infrastructure nerd everywhere i
travel all my pictures are of
infrastructure
um and not people and so i started
following both of our speakers tonight a
long time ago
and
we've had each of them separately for
talks at the interval uh over the years
and and i remember when we had the last
one with uh with nicola uh i asked her
what was the project that she's working
on next and she said oh well i've been
working on this book about the
the the coming quarantine for several
years with jeff and she said started the
project back in 2015 and um are now it
was going to be about the coming
quarantine and is now about
the history and the future of quarantine
so welcome
jeff mano and nicola twilly
[Applause]
cool thank you
for the introduction xander so what we
wanted to do tonight
is nikki and i would be presenting uh
just some of the themes from the book uh
until proven safe the most important
thing i'd say with any kind of
conversation about quarantine is just
making sure that we know what we're
talking about from a vocabulary point of
view that we're using the right
definitions and and thus the correct
words as is still the case even in the
medical community um the words isolation
and quarantine are very often used
interchangeably so isolation and brief
medical isolation means that you know
you're infected you know you have a
disease you know that something is
dangerous it's been diagnosed as such
and you're keeping it spatially or
temporally separate from you and it's in
a state of isolation so for example when
president trump tested positive for
kovid and then and then tweeted that he
was undergoing a quarantine process in
true trumpian fashion that was the wrong
use of the word he was actually
undergoing an isolation process but in
any case quarantine then and the reason
why we were really drawn to it a
quarantine requires uncertainty
quarantine means you do not know if you
have an infection you don't know if you
have a disease you don't know if this
this thing approaching you is infected
or contaminated it might be an object or
an animal or a relative but the whole
point is that you are unsure of whether
or not this this thing this person this
entity
will be a risk to you and quarantine is
the act of keeping yourself separate
from it to see if that threat emerges
from within and so when looked at that
way quarantine immediately turns into a
really interesting series of metaphors
it becomes the possibility that we all
have something monstrous lurking within
ourselves but we have to give it the
space and time to be revealed
it turns into something where it's not
just metaphoric but even has religious
overtones or theological overtones and
that's something that is actually
augmented or emphasized even by the word
quarantine itself which comes from the
old venetian dialect for quarantina
which means 40 quarants of journey is 40
days quarantine is supposed to be a
40-day process 40 was not chosen
numerically for medical purposes
in fact originally quarantine was 30
days it was a trentine
trentina
but 40 was a way of tying this
experience back to biblical notions of
you know christ's alleged 40 days and 40
nights in the desert the 40 days of lent
the 40 days and 40 nights of rain that
we encounter in the story of noah's ark
even the 40 as a just sort of a general
number that is approximately the length
of a generation in
in hebrew culture
and so
40 then ties quarantine back to this
sort of religious metaphoric sense that
was something that was really exciting
that we wanted to explore with the book
but then fundamentally i'd say
quarantine is the way that we model the
unknown and we often do that through a
lens or a filter of fear and quarantine
is is how we give shape to the the
period of encountering it
yes so because as jeff says
when someone is being quarantined they
are not a certain danger we merely
suspect that they might pose a risk um
you get into the question of risk
perception and as we all know risk
perception is subject to bias whether
unconscious or otherwise it's also a
very dangerous and powerful tool it's
one of the few instances in today's
world where you are an anglo-saxon legal
thought for example where you are
essentially guilty until proven innocent
you are contagious until proven safe in
the book we tell the story of the
american plan
which is the largest recent mass
quarantine that most americans have
never heard of it started in 1917 and
under its powers tens of thousands of
so-called loose women
were detained on suspicion of spreading
venereal disease um
and there was no legal recourse for them
so the this is something to bear in mind
with quarantine a long history that
something that is fundamentally based on
uncertainty and suspicion
risks then giving a scientific
endorsement to existing biases um and
and our existing perceived monsters as
it were
and so a great example i think of just
how foundational quarantine and
isolation and the logics of separation
are to the mythology in particular here
of the west is the story of alexander's
gates this is something that we describe
in the book the legend of alexander's
gates are that alexander the great the
conqueror allegedly whilst leading his
army through the caucasus region of
central asia
had his workers construct and weld
together huge iron gates these gates
would stand in the in a mountain pass
somewhere in the caucasus and would hold
at bay a kind of monstrous eastern other
thus it being the caucasus mountains
helping to literally define the the
caucasian west against this kind of
seething world of deformity and incoming
monstrosity and so actually the myth was
taken so seriously at the time even
though it's just a folktale that
actually maps of the time
often feature a band of iron and one in
certain parts of the map that were meant
to represent this idea of alexander's
gates kind of holding the the east at
bay
there's an interesting individual um
stephen asma who wrote a book that looks
at monsters and how they're figured in
western mythology what it means when we
come up with a new monster what that
monster represents how we crystallized a
certain series of fears into that figure
and he writes about alexander's gates
and it's quite interesting that as is
the case with many of the stories of
quarantine including some that we'll
talk about this evening often quarantine
fails because of some very very small
vulnerability some minor event or some
minor actor or character who
comes into the picture and and makes the
entire scheme fall apart in this case
it's quote unquote a lowly fox
a fox actually
being a curious animal
digs through from the western side under
the gates and into the monster zone as
asthma calls it the monsters are kind of
you know shocked and surprised to see a
fox and follow it back into the western
world and this is what asthma calls the
realm of the reprobate is is unleashed
upon the west but this is just a new
version or rather a different version of
the doomsday myth that when these gates
that you know keep our world separate
from the world of monsters falls apart
you know we become a victim of the
things that we've been trying to hold
separate from us for for in this case
thousands of years
when in the 1950s it first became sort
of clear that rockets were actually
sufficiently advanced that we were
maybe going to get to space people
started to worry what will happen when
alien biospheres collide planetary
quarantine became the planetary
protection which became
international law and it encompasses two
different strands so one is ford
contamination
that's bringing earth life to
extraterrestrial environments a couple
of reasons for this one earth life might
wipe out alien life and also it might
just make it really hard to know if we
found alien life for bringing life with
us there's also back contamination and
that is when we are bringing
samples or people back from
extraterrestrial environments now this
became an issue during the apollo
missions
and so it involved the cdc sort of
officially said hey you're not bringing
the astronauts back unless they go into
quarantine
and nasa said oh well we didn't think
there was life on the moon so we weren't
planning that and had to scramble so
they retrofitted an airstream trailer
put the astronauts and the lunar samples
in it
brought them back to houston where they
had constructed the lunar receiving lab
essentially a quarantine facility
and then they declared a federal
quarantine there to prevent the risk of
contaminating earth with
extraterrestrial life which is the only
time there's been a quarantine against
extraterrestrial life in the federal
register
and then you know
eventually realized there was no need
for that there was no life on the moon
but what's interesting about this is if
quarantine is about uncertainty
then planetary quarantine is sort of a
fractal example of uncertainty we have
no idea
if there is life elsewhere in the
universe and if so if it poses a danger
to earth life we have no idea if earth
life would pose a danger to it or even
if earth life would be capable of
replicating in extraterrestrial
environments so what do you do when
you're trying to minimize risk with no
data and yet
kind of existential stakes but what we
wanted to really do throughout the book
was see where quarantine was being
experimented with or the technical
limits of isolation were being pushed
today where would such a person go this
is down in a salt mine known as the
waste isolation pilot plant it's outside
carlsbad new mexico it's near the border
with texas
so to be clear it's not a quarantine
facility for nuclear waste which i'll
get to in a second it's an isolation
facility and on top of that it's a pilot
plant so it's an experimental facility
but so this is where uh nuclear waste is
being buried by the us government it's
not the kind of nuclear waste that you
might picture but it's nuclear waste in
the sense of fabrics and gowns and
gloves and scientific equipment like
microscopes desks pens papers that were
used by scientists in laboratories where
they were developing the nation's
nuclear arsenal
and so those materials that may may or
may not be contaminated but also do pose
a risk to the biosphere are being
shipped to new mexico they're being put
into giant caskets and then they're
being lowered into the depths of the
earth 2150 feet into these huge salt
deposits the room itself is very roughly
the size of a tennis court and then
there's 56 of those rooms throughout
these panels so when you go down into
the depths and drive around through the
salt
you know you can often enter into
hallways where it's difficult even
necessarily to see the very end of it
but so there are several interesting
things here one is that the salt is
actually a kind of a plastic mineral
what i mean by that is that when you
apply enough pressure to it salt moves
almost like a marshmallow or was
described to us as molasses in january
and so when you look closely and you can
see it a little bit in this photograph
the salt is actually crushing its way
back into these corridors and rooms but
that's by design so salt is not only
resistant to radiation and can block it
so it's already a shield against these
the radio isotopes that are being
emitted from the uh from the waste or or
should there be an accident um but also
the whole point is that once humans
abandon this architectural structure and
uh no longer go down into it the salt
will just continue to crush it'll
squeeze in and basically form a kind of
crystalline tomb for all of the things
that are buried within it there's a a
project
that really caught our attention because
it was something that we found
throughout the history of quarantine
which was how do you communicate risk to
individuals and to people and how do
they believe what you're saying so if
you're trying to convince people
thousands of generations from now and
you're dealing with nuclear waste that's
going to be dangerous for at least 10
000 and possibly many millions of years
how do you convince them that this is in
fact a dangerous substance that they
should not in fact dig it up and that
it's something to be avoided you know we
saw even during covet 19 that people
didn't believe that covid and still
don't believe that it's a real disease
that think that the vaccine is actually
a bio weapon you know there are people
that don't if you don't trust the
information that's coming to you why on
earth would you trust some sign that you
found that was written 8 000 years ago
and it's in the middle of the desert
telling you not to dig
so that may sound like a very niche
thing to be concerned about but in fact
there's a lot of real worry that that
whip is going to be disinterred and so
beginning in the 1980s uh there was a
series of department of energy funded
roundtables that looked at bringing
together semioticians anthropologists
linguists experts in religion
even experts in radiation sickness and
brought them all together to kind of
brainstorm what we could do to prepare
future generations to believe the
message of danger some is kind of
titanic land art there's one that's a
giant landscape of thorns where made of
concrete the idea apparently being that
you know aggressive geometric shapes
would be just so terrifying that people
will leave and they won't they would
never consider digging there another one
one of my personal favorites was a it
was a i guess the department of energy
in the 1980s was so
sensitive to the site of edvard monk's
famous painting the scream but that that
was considered so terrifying in the
1980s apparently that edvard amongst the
screen was going to be reproduced at
various scales throughout the website in
order to scare future generations from
digging there another one was the raycat
proposal which was actually to make cats
genetically modify domestic house cats
so that if cats came into the region and
there was there was loose radiation and
then radionuclides in the environment
the cats would change color and
potentially even emit fluorescent light
and somehow people with these cats would
conclude from that that there must be a
leaking underground radio a radiation
source and they'll leave the greater
carlsbad area and and go to where their
cats no longer glow the whole point of
whip is that we can take something a
glove that may or may not have traces of
plutonium on it we can take that from a
site somewhere else in the united states
bring it all the way to new mexico and
bury it ostensibly for eternity
but so to do all of that with billions
of dollars in spence it was a 100 000
page environmental application in order
to get whip constructed it was thus like
the lowly fox that brings down
alexander's gates it was eye-opening and
sobering to realize that in or to hear
rather that in 2014 kitty litter almost
undid the entire thing so there was an
explosion and a barrel erupted down in
the depths of whip and released
radiation throughout its own little
panel it's so much so that it caused 500
million dollars worth of damage uh parts
of whip can no longer be used for their
function which ironically is to bury
nuclear waste but it's considered too
dangerous to go into them and they've
been sealed off
and radionuclides actually were vented
beyond the site but the guy who figured
out what happened realized that someone
had packed
these barrels using the wrong kind of
kitty litter they'd used organic kitty
litter which is based as a wheat based
absorbent it sounds really good it's
organic but normally it would be a
clay-based absorbent which can help with
the radionuclides and so there was a
chemical reaction between the wheat and
the radiation that caused the explosion
the same person who figured that out
realized that 700 barrels were packed
with the same kitty litter and so far
only one of them has exploded
so while we were at whip we were
reminded of this strange contraption
which is the high level isolation unit
in london the royal free hospital in
london in england which is used as an
isolation facility or a quarantine
facility mostly for hemorrhagic diseases
so this is me inside a trexler unit but
the way it works is that the person who
is either suspected of having ebola or
has it
hops inside this tent and the doctors
and nurses caring for them
just kind of sort of insert themselves
into these suits built into the tent
wall this is me inside it
immediately after the dr jacobs told me
that they had cleaned it using an
experimental decontamination procedure
after the last inhabitant left that was
a scottish nurse with ebola so um
there i am there he is and he as he
explains all he has to do and i i quote
him is imaginate himself into the wall
uh to provide care and so what what's
interesting about this
is
the uk is completely unique in doing
isolation this way and and actually mike
jacobs told us
they get ridiculed for this people laugh
at them everywhere else in the world
provides care for people with infectious
diseases using ppe
and this is a this is jeff you might not
recognize him here on the left in full
pbe with our guide to quarantine who we
met in venice who turned out to be the
chief scientific officer in charge of
italy's covid response later he had jeff
dress up in ppe to sort of show us
what this is like it's extremely hot
it's extremely hard to put on and take
off without the risk of infection that's
something that people train repeatedly
and still get wrong and you also look
like an alien whereas in the trexler
unit
when you're invaginated into the wall
you are not as hot you don't look like
an alien and anyone can do it so
non-trained experts can do it and also
family members can do it so this became
interesting to us and apparently
interesting to others too
we were talking to
doctors who were caring for ebola
patients in the drc in 2018 and they
were telling us we have a really hard
time persuading people to go into
quarantine and isolation because the
culture is
don't be separate from your family
particularly when you're sick that's
just absolutely not the right thing to
do and so people would just resist
quarantine and isolation well congolese
doctors saw the trexler unit and adapted
it for use in the congo these are these
low budget versions of the cube that
have been extremely effective and to us
that was
kind of a reminder that quarantine can
be redesigned and that something that is
keeping you separate from your community
for your protection and for their
protection
cannot still be designed in such a way
that it keeps you connected to your
community
interestingly and we were fascinated to
see this at the start of the covet
pandemic this was adopted in in the u.s
too so there was some prototype units
being rolled out in boston in june um
that's a hug suit built into the wall of
one of these cubes and what's
fascinating about this is you probably
remember there was this shortage of ppe
well
one of these units replaces 200 full
sets of ppe
again allows family members to visit and
everyone doesn't have to look like an
alien and it can pop up anywhere so when
the hospitals were getting overwhelmed
this was a viable sort of
way to provide care outside of a ward so
really interesting for us to be
imaginative and redesign quarantine as
an experience
um so one of the images that we open the
book with is a description of how
quarantine facilities first kind of came
into the national consciousness at the
beginning of covid there was this really
extraordinary scene that happened up
outside seattle washington where the
local health authority had purchased an
econo lodge motel
because there was no place for for
quarantining they didn't have the
infrastructure or the architecture or
the facilities to do it and so they sent
a crew out wearing ppe they stepped out
of a van walked over to the econolide
sign and then just started painting it
black
it was like a you know a slayer video
and so they just gradually the sign that
set is still glowing econo lodge is just
gradually replaced by this matte black
rectangle like a pirate flag kind of
hanging over the street that just
basically said the previous function of
this building has been canceled um this
is now a quarantine facility
so quarantine it presents an interesting
infrastructural challenge we've already
talked about some of the logistics of it
how to get waste or how to get infected
people or potentially infected people
rather from one place to another to
another
you know how one can interact with them
if you're a doctor or a family but then
finding enough space in a time of mass
quarantine is a huge architectural
challenge
and so someone else that we met for the
book was the now former head of the army
corps of engineers
um which is the us agency who
effectively is put in charge of building
things of making changing the landscape
building dams and levees and hospitals
and whatnot and what was quite
interesting was that he pointed out some
things about the otherwise perceived
aesthetic limitations of the american
landscape the sort of cookie-cutterness
aspect of it the fact that hotel chains
when you drive out of a city you'll see
the same series of of the three or four
different hotels three or four different
gas stations three or four different
subdivisions that are all designed and
constructed by the same company um this
kind of similarity this this jg
balardian
identical nature of the american
landscape actually lends itself very
well to mass quarantine one of the
things we did while we were reporting
the book as we went to
pandemic simulations and so these are
essentially like role playing exercises
where world leaders domestic leaders
gather
and try to game out their responses to a
disease outbreak
one of the ones the the most recent ones
we went to before covet 19 was called
event 201
so named because the world health
organization deals with an average of
200 epidemic events each year and they
figured it was only a matter of time
before one of those had global pandemic
potential
as it happens event 201 which happened
in october 2019
was simulating
a novel coronavirus
the thing about these simulations is you
saw the same mistakes made again and
again and each time you know the the
organizers would write reports with
recommendations most of which echoed the
last report
but one of the most sort of striking
features of them is that each time we
were there people would say ah okay so
this is where we implement quarantine
and then they would move on as if
quarantine was a drug or a vaccine
not as if quarantine was a lived
experience that people have that has to
be implemented it has to be enforced it
has to be endured people have to go
somewhere and do something and so that
aspect of quarantine was completely
overlooked as a as a lived experience
the fact of the matter is quarantine
itself is extremely boring and it always
has been there are letters from you know
the priest in charge of managing
quarantine in 1600s genoa saying what
are these women i'm in charge of
supposed to do all day
there are letters from 18th century
aristocrats saying i've written letters
to everyone i know i've tallied up all
my expense reports and now i'm going
slowly mad you know and then you have
covert 19 where you know the british
public spent half their waking hours
watching netflix literally calculated
during during the first lockdown so it's
boring and everyone knows that so how to
fix it we spoke to a boredom researcher
for the book and she said well you know
boredom it's not really a a thing it's
just a signal
that you're not engaged in what you're
doing and you're not finding it
meaningful quarantine should be a
meaningful experience um you are doing
something making a personal sacrifice
for the public good it just doesn't feel
like that so
how do we redesign reimagine it give it
some experience design and that sounds
frivolous but it isn't and now is the
moment to do it because we are going to
experience quarantine again in our
lifetimes now is the time with the
insights that we have from kovid19 to
ask what should quarantine look like in
the future
uh so the the future of quarantine you
know i think
as you can see from what we're talking
about it really doesn't require a
technical solution it requires more of
an emotional or even spiritual or
a narrative solution something that
gives quarantine meaning however you
find that in your own life but
nevertheless the technical perfection of
quarantine is something that many many
people are now trying to to figure out
as healthcare
data and uh
smart home sort of technology uh all
combine into one massive edifice one of
the things that we come back to is
actually these companies that are moving
into
the quarantine space moving into a way
to try to make quarantine so that it can
be predictive it can be algorithmically
implemented it can be more precise it
can be something where you know one
single individual out of thousands can
be chosen can be found maybe even
preemptively quarantined to save the 999
other people and the the the technical
possibility of that goal
without necessarily thinking of the
moral or ethical risks or even the
constitutional risks that come with
pursuing it
in this case we're actually looking at a
patent diagram there was an actual
patent filed by amazon so that it's a
echo digital speaker could recognize
sounds of illness and depression in
people who were speaking or coughing
around it so if you are coughing or
sniffling it might offer a you could
purchase cough drops uh you could
subscribe to something on amazon if you
sounded depressed or lonely it would
offer maybe something from your
a previously viewed video selection that
might cheer you up again the notion that
a private company would step into those
kinds of mental health decisions public
health decisions is something that i
think has some relatively ominous
overtones for the future but what we see
emerging i think out of the assisted
living world for elder care is i think
the future of the domestic environment
and thus the future of quarantine so you
see a lot of assisted living facilities
getting technology implemented and
integrated into the rooms themselves and
using things like doppler radar for
telling if a body is moving through a
room and at what pace because if you
suddenly change gait dramatically there
might be a physical injury involved
sensors in the floors that can tell if
someone has fallen over so that they can
send nursing staff in to rescue you they
can also tell if there's a gait
difference maybe you've had a stroke
cameras behind the mirrors that can see
skin tone so maybe
you are having cardiac issues or you
have a fever or some other kind of a
bodily event has happened to you but so
this medical diagnostic equipment uh
which which at the moment is just part
of you know taking care of the elderly
will undoubtedly trickle down into
everyday domestic spaces but so what
happens with this and i think what the
risk is is that
if you already have a world which is the
world we live in where an internet
search giant has access to things that
we've been looking up you know google
tried something about several years ago
called google flu trends that was
looking at whether or not you could tell
you could find hot spots for flu
outbreaks in the united states based on
what thing what people were searching
for
if that same company also owns some of
these other diagnostic appliances that
will live in the smart homes of the
future if they also control your front
door lock or if they own the camera that
you have at your front door you're
beginning to see the outlines of a
system that could say not unlock the
front door until you show proof of
vaccination or not let you for that
matter leave the leave your house unless
you're going to a doctor's appointment
and there is actually a car on the way
to pick you up
you have the possibility of
algorithmically induced quarantine being
implemented by the buildings themselves
in a way that escapes many of the
constitutional or public health concerns
or even ways to push back against
quarantine that we haven't really gotten
into tonight but that we talk about in
the book a right of appeal that kind of
thing
another risk very briefly though is just
that there's a false promise in all of
this and i think it's that
if we give private corporations the
ability to make health care decisions
for us or for their algorithms to make
health care decisions for us we're
assuming that public health is actually
the goal of what they're doing
but of course a well populous a healthy
populace healthy customers are not
necessarily what they have in mind
and so you know it isn't necessarily the
the greatest thing for this business
market to suddenly help everyone get
over the illnesses that they're being
held in their homes for and i think that
that's one of the
certainly one of the moral risks of of
the future of quarantine the other thing
is this belief that big data and
algorithmic analysis will give us
enough information to make quarantines
ever more precise to turn this blunt
medieval instrument into something for
the 21st century that
hardly hurts at all it's it sounds
compelling tech companies believe they
can do it
but
as weather forecasters have found you
can feed more data into the model you
can have sensors everywhere and you
still can't tell what the weather is
going to be like here in fort mason in a
month's time so there is a limit to what
can be modeled the other thing that
digital
technology
enabled quarantine seems to promise is
you know the the idea that we can slice
and dice quarantine politicians were
quick to leap on that to say well let's
have these color-coded tears and let's
have these micro restrictions where you
can be with three families if it's
outside but only one family inside and
you can have people in a support bubble
and this was all sort of calculated
and yet those kinds of quarantine
restrictions those kinds of restrictions
on mobility and interaction proved less
effective because the logic behind them
was so opaque and appeared not to be
even understood by the politicians who
were advocating them
let alone followed by them in most cases
and so that unfair and unenforceable
essentially kind of precision quarantine
actually
may well not be the solution
and so with that i'm going to
bring us to a close by saying it was
really bizarre to be finishing a book
about quarantine during covet 19 and
lockdown but it was actually more so
frustrating
we in the history of quarantine saw
every single mistake that happened
during covet 19 had happened before
and there's a natural urge to say well
when the pandemic's over can we move on
can we forget can we not learn and
that's the wrong move we need to
redesign quarantine not just because
we're going to experience it again as i
said but also because it is shaping the
world around us and i give just a quick
example here the passport which is now
the
piece of paper that regulates our
movement around the world its ancestor
is the health passport
which was first pioneered in what is now
italy in the uh 1500s as a way of
avoiding quarantine you would get one of
these documents and it would say that
you were coming from a place that was
healthy and not diseased and that would
allow you to dodge quarantine well that
has hardened into a piece of paper that
determines exit and entry around the
world and the same thing is true we in
the book we trace national borders that
are former quarantine lines we trace
bureaucracies even the united nations
itself
back to uh disease control measures
you can see the start of this happening
now this is the alipay system in china
that is being used to
regulate movement that this kind of
thing
it's a temporary thing
an emergency thing that starts happening
during pandemics and then hardens into
the new reality and so yes we live in a
world that is shaped by quarantine's
past and our future is being built from
today's lockdown as we speak
thank you
well thank you guys that was fantastic
and could not be more
appropriate of a topic what was
interesting i think obviously about this
quarantine that we're in is that in some
ways it was the least boring quarantine
in history right like we had
we had access to world most of the world
a lot of the world i guess had access to
world news
we could a lot of people could work from
home um in certain types of ways or at
least communicate from home um
how do you think that that's a where do
you think that fits in the spectrum of
the history of quarantine
um i guess i'd say a couple things there
i mean it's it's it's
one of the things that really struck me
about
the lockdown for kovid was how many
people were inspired to change their
lives precisely because they got to see
their life through a kind of intolerable
lens of of a groundhog day like
permanence you know this is the thing
the very things that people would have
said would have been you know say their
perfect sunday uh you know that they're
gonna stay home they're gonna watch
netflix uh they're gonna you know
just read books on the couch when you're
told that that's what you have to do and
that that's an inescapable fate and that
this is the thing that you're going to
be doing for for you for you know
another 12 months
suddenly your own everyday life becomes
intolerable and i think that that was
one of the things that inspired um so
many life changes you know we had people
that moved out of los angeles where we
where we live um marriages amongst our
friends fell apart uh relationships
broke up people quit their jobs they
moved to you know boise
uh doing things to just just get a
change from los angeles is my point um
but so i think that that was one one
thing that was that was quite
interesting about it but i think also
um in the history of quarantine i guess
the other thing i'd say is that
originally speaking 600 years ago
quarantine was actually a communal
experience so when we went into we
humanity went into quarantine um it
would be with our neighbors and our
family and the the other crew members on
ships that we had arrived with whole
neighborhoods might go into quarantine
together churches would go into
quarantine together they'd go to the
lazaretto they would go to an external
facility and cycle through that facility
uh almost ritualistically and that ties
into that idea of
the the religious overtones of
quarantine this was a period of
cleansing you know we're going to go
through it together and we're going to
emerge a new
proven safe and go back to our everyday
life and so it's quite interesting that
now quarantine
is almost means exactly the opposite of
that it's this atomized experience it's
going off to be alone it's you know sort
of hiding off in an apartment of our own
so i think that that's one of the
interesting ways i think that this kind
of can be both compared to and
contrasted with the history of
quarantine that's interesting and i
think
you know germ theory was is relatively
new yet clearly people were
understanding this in some in some way
and you know and my understanding of the
of the massive pandemic in in north
america when westerners first arrived
was so much it was so exacerbated by the
fact that when somebody got sick the
family would come around those people
and then of course get more and more
people sick but it does seem that in at
least in parts of history i mean what
how what is the earliest pandemic that
we know about it's it's certainly before
germ theory was
figured out by a lot absolutely and one
of the things we look at in the book is
why did quarantine emerge where and when
it did like who
you know because there's no if you if
you don't have germ theory there's no
scientific reason that you would think
that separation and isolation is the way
to go um and
it's
it emerged in we don't you know we
didn't talk about this in the in the
talk but it emerged in uh the adriatic
sea
when the black death first arrived in
europe at the time europe had had
centuries of freedom from
um epidemic disease that infectious
disease
and so this was sort of a novel
terrifying thing that had made its way
from
the east you know broadly speaking and
reached uh
europe with trade goods
and
one of the you know
merchants really just wanted to preserve
the source of their world wealth which
was trading with the east
while not all dying and so quarantine
was this idea that we could just sort of
park the ship outside on an island
initially you know just offshore um and
see if it was safe or not
because they could correlate the arrival
of trade goods with
um
with the outbreaks of the black death
and and the so there's this this idea of
observation there um you know these are
merchants uh who are watching the flow
of business there's also uh
an element of you know not you know in
some in some
regions if you would think that you know
a plague is a is a punishment from god
or a misalignment of the stars then
quarantine makes no sense you wouldn't
you know you wouldn't have a reason to
implement it you would instead pray or
or hope for the stars to realign
themselves um and then the other piece
is that this was part of the republic of
venice and it was
um not a democracy in the sense that we
know it today but there was an elected
leader and there was a sense of
public
and public responsibility and
responsibility for public health in that
leadership and i think
and people being answerable
to the community and that sense of
public is actually essential to public
health um and again is one of the
reasons why quarantine emerged where it
did whereas in the new world where there
were far fewer animals to be
domesticated there were fewer zoonotic
diseases and then and thus fewer
pandemics to be dealt with so there
there's a sort of ecological political
cultural religious logic to quarantine
emerging where and when it did
i think one of the things that you guys
touched on in your talk and that became
painfully clear i think to all of us and
certainly did to me
in going through a quarantine is that is
how imperfect it is
right like and i remember talking to the
scientists in biosphere 2 and they're
like well we still have ants that we
don't know where they came from you know
it's like they're trying to isolate so
heavily and you know as we were all
wiping down our groceries at the
beginning of this thing and we you know
you'd still then you'd realize oh i just
brought that thing and i don't you know
it was just like it was all it's all
imperfect um at all levels i'm sure and
you know it's we have some of the
diseases that some of the worst diseases
that have escaped have have been from
labs have level four labs right so
that imperfection i think is the thing
that
makes this so human and so you know the
whole thing is built of humans
and so it's just not really good
how do we how do we wrestle with that
well so quarantine is always leaky and
in fact the um the head of the cdc's
division of global migration and
quarantine uh went back and when he
started in the job he wanted to abolish
quarantine get rid of it from the name
didn't think it was a useful tool
anymore
you know it was the end of the 20th
century at the time coming into the 21st
century surely we could do better than
this medieval tool
and he went back and analyzed uh
outbreaks for which there was actually
good data which was primarily the
1918-1919 flu and he realized oh
quarantine does work and it works even
when it's leaky in fact sometimes a
leaky quarantine works better than a
quarantine that you're enforcing heavily
because then you don't actually know
where the escapees went
but
so the data shows that it does work and
the reason it works is because it's
working at a public scale
it's working and and marty cetron this
is the directive of quarantine the cdc
he was actually the one who originally
coined the term that we all heard um
this time last year of flattening the
curve
um so it's working at the public scale
it's reducing transmission it's not
eliminating transmission it's not
eliminating risk and i think that's
what's so interesting about it is it is
flawed and it is leaky so it starts to
seem pointless because we want certainty
but as we said quarantine depends on
uncertainty and it involves uncertainty
and it is about reducing transmission
not eliminating it that feels incredibly
unsatisfactory but that
to me that's that's what makes it so
scientific science science is a process
of trying to get closer to certainty
rather than actually kind of arriving at
it i think that misperception um you
know
we all want certain certainty we don't
want to live with nuance and finding a
way to make us comfortable with nuance
and uncertainty and knowledge
progressing is the way to go
yeah well it's that's the nuclear waste
is like that too i remember i visited a
lot of nuclear waste sites like yucca
mountain and and ankalo and europe and
and you know scientists are always
charged with making a hundred percent
safe facility and then someone asked
them the question how can you be sure in
a hundred thousand years that this is
safe and they just like well we can't
it's a it's a it's a very interesting
problem and
just briefly along those lines um what's
interesting too is that uh
many of the people that were actually
tasked to write about uh the waste
isolation pilot plant and look at the
risk of what's called advertent entry so
that's people that are deliberately
trying to get into whip
they're basically just saying there is
no way to
stop this you know it's not a
burglary-proof vault if you're going to
drill into whip you can do it um and so
there's basically no way to just you
know to make people not do that but
there was a really interesting quote
from an individual who we put in the
book um i can't remember it verbatim but
the the paraphrase is basically if you
look at the the history of uh
human uh facilities that have you know
been buried or put in the center of a
pyramid or a tomb uh that has been of
interest to archaeologists um when you
look at how humans deal with things that
have been hidden away or buried um you
know basically none of our nuclear waste
facilities have any chance of becoming
you know of actually fulfilling their
long-term promise and for somebody in
the nuclear waste industry to say that
it's a bit like okay so you know
you mentioned that whole project of how
to market and and you know a lot of the
results of that if you look at the
markings that were on the outside of
king tut's tomb they you know they said
you know your family will become sick
for generations like it's basically all
the same things we mark a nuclear waste
site but it's nothing you know it
nothing makes you want to think there's
gold on the other side of that door more
than that they didn't have glowing cats
there yeah the glowing cats
sorry the other thing that i just
thought was so funny is that the
department of energy um in one of their
papers they actually bragged that they
they finally chose these giant uh
granite blocks and that's what they're
going to carve their warning message
into um but they actually brag in one of
their uh
white papers that that their their rock
is better than stonehenge
anyways it was pretty amazing nice yeah
i went to one of these conferences of
the geological repository uh leaders and
they all know that the right answer is
to not mark nuclear waste it's the
safest thing to do and but they all know
that is a politically impossible answer
for them to give so it's an interesting
problem um kevin kelly asks um so let's
say contagious viruses are going to be
the norm for urban humanity what do you
think our response is going to look like
in 50 years
the optimistic version or the
i mean i i do feel that um
we are going to leave this to um the
tech
industry and
we are going to
uh live in a world where
at the flick of a switch our own
individual movements will be restricted
using
whatever we are
whatever technology we have by then so i
feel like the trend that we are seeing
where private companies are moving into
it and we are
increasingly living in
censored environments
our entire body is monitored at all time
that trend will allow
um either public health authorities or
in fact companies delegated to
execute on public health contracts to
kind of switch individuals into
lazaretto mode where your your movements
are restricted and those around those of
the people around you or not it's not
what i want to see happen but that's
what i think will happen
excellent yeah i think the
these are
among the types of events like
earthquakes and asteroid impacts
that are 100 predicted
but you know not when but that they will
happen um but that humanity seems to be
not so good at remembering um you know
just 100 years ago that the last one
that we had
and how to prepare for it mollystar asks
what part of your research
surprised you the most
i mean it was
the planetary quarantine stuff was
pretty surprising to me
two parts of it one the fact that you
know nasa straight ahead goes and says
yes there's life on mars because we
brought it um so planetary quarantine
has already failed and and second of all
i hadn't really realized the lengths to
which um you know the cdc had said it
would refuse entry to the apollo
astronauts um if they weren't in
quarantine and then
the the the fact that you know the plan
for the lunar receiving lab if an alien
replicating agent had been discovered
was literally to bury it and everyone in
it alive under a mountain of rock and
dirt
um
that that was a
that's just part of the apollo story you
don't usually hear that was surprising
yeah i'd say that there wasn't a lot of
like macro scale stuff that was too
surprising it was definitely the
granular details of the stories that
that really kind of struck struck me as
well i mean one one detail that um i'm
specifically mentioning it precisely
because it's not in the book and i kick
myself every time i i i say it just
because i wish we had included it um you
know i've mentioned you know like the
lowly fox that brings down alexander's
gates the kitty litter that that almost
blew up whip um we went to a place in uh
saint paul minnesota where they deal
with very very pathogen virulent
pathogens that would attack the wheat
supply or other agricultural commodities
in the united states
they actually only use these or research
them in the winter months
because minnesota itself is considered
in winter is considered a quarantine
barrier
and so you know if it were to escape
from the lab it would basically you know
freeze and die in the in the in the
extreme you know minnesota uh weather
which i also think is funny because i've
relatives in minnesota but it's so bleak
that uh you know it it's a it's a
quarantine site but um they were worried
that this place this facility that they
researched is actually too close to the
university athletic fields and they have
a very specific worry the worry is that
an over strong javelin thrower
will some summer throw the javelin too
ambitiously and it will actually go over
the the athletic fields and it will
pierce the side of this
pathogenic wheat research laboratory
and it's a greenhouse
to yeah aka a greenhouse yeah but um
and thus you know the the the great
global food apocalypse you know will be
unleashed by a a university of minnesota
javelin thrower
[Laughter]
nice um
i i i have to say i was really surprised
to hear that
uh that there was a global pandemic uh
simulation in october of 2019 and the
head of china's
uh you know cdc was there and i'll never
forget one of the very first
news stories that i saw on this was an
aerial shot of
like 65 excavators building a quarantine
facility in wuhan and going
whoa they're building a hospital in
three days
and it was like clearly they had a
different mental model than we did um
and and it was it was born out
and actually the chinese uh then when
italy started uh you know going through
its first coveted way
chinese health officials came to it you
know offer advice and their experience
and they suggested building these
centralized quarantine facilities so not
just isolation but quarantine if you had
been exposed if a family member
tested positive you should be rounded up
and put in a centralized quarantine
facility and that's what they built in
in wuhan and elsewhere in china and
and used and that's what they thought
was effective and the italians said well
thanks but that's not possible here um
when we spoke to todd semonite of the
army corps of engineers he said well
yeah that's what we did in the military
centralized quarantine yep we knew it
worked
but uh not possible for the american
public when we spoke to the director of
the cdc division of quarantine um you
know in october 2020 well into the into
the pandemic he said yeah we had these
debates it's a bit like the nuclear uh
repository folks he said the best thing
would have been centralized quarantine
but it was politically unfeasible so
it's a you know in china politically
unfeasible is a different um calculus so
um kevin kelly asks um who is actively
redesigning
uh quarantine today and where do you go
to get a design
well i think that
although it would be fascinating if
there was like an amazon quarantine
division um i think that actually it's a
sort of a piecemeal gradual reinvention
of quarantine that is happening we see
it you know through some of the things
that we were discussing in terms of
elder care and assisted living know
those technologies are extremely useful
when it comes to quarantine
um or medical diagnosis uh more
generally um actually todd semonite the
former head of the army corps of
engineers pointed out that um some of
the solutions that he's pursuing are
really almost just like a home depot
reward shopper sort of paradise so that
the kinds of things you would buy if
you're doing home renovations
like the zip up dust barriers that you
put in your house if someone is doing
you know maybe they're polishing the
hardwood floors in one room over
those dust barriers can be repurposed
for medical isolation
air conditioning units can can do the
same thing
but so my point is that i think that
it's interesting actually that
quarantine
is being sort of piecemeal redesigned in
real time now by people that are trying
to figure out ways to
make home delivery services more
efficient
to maybe redesign
offices from
open plan to maybe going back to the
cubicle model
but i do think actually that there is a
obvious business model uh opening up
that would is going to be interesting to
see who steps into it um you know where
people do come up with ways to reinvent
quarantine to redesign domestic houses
so that they are better at allowing
isolation you know which is perfect for
moody teenagers but also people who
might have coveted 19 or kovid 25 or
whatever it might be one of the most
interesting examples in the book of
someone who's redesigning quarantine was
chevron of all people and so the energy
giant um and they are uh
they're doing this and it's it's kind of
a long story so i'll tell the short
version um in order to be able to
extract the natural gas under this
pristine island off the coast of
australia they have to completely
quarantine this island um
from invasive species or you know any of
the normal things that have sort of
decimated
much of the rest of australia um rabbits
rats cockroaches all have to be kept off
this island um and in so doing they have
completely rethought what quarantine
looks like and one of the things that's
that's fascinating is they actually have
sort of gamified it in a way so they
worked with computer frame designers to
design something called quarantine hero
and
that to me
there's you know there's much more to
say about what they're doing but that to
me was the sort of creativity
incentivizing quarantine making
quarantine rewarding fun
addictive i mean we
know how to design those kinds of
experiences but quarantine hasn't been
designed that way and
chevron is doing it because they are
they want access to natural gas but no
one's doing it for public health and i
wish they were
well and as a follow-on to that you know
there was some some of these
technological things that started coming
showing themselves in covad like the
using cell phone aggregate cell phone
tracking data to see you know how well
people are actually isolating um
[Music]
you know i think you guys are speaking
about the dangers of some of these
technologies but i think was is that a
case of maybe gamification and aggregate
data being used well would you say
that's interesting i mean if it if it
could be translated into something that
made it rewarding and also made you feel
connected to the people that you were
protecting then yeah i mean data does
not have to be used for bad it's just
that
um or for ill it's just that uh what is
the incentive for corporations to to
use it for good
and
um stephen hubbard actually asked this
question that i think is a good
follow-on to that which is you know
this the history and the the evaluation
and costs of proactive uh forms of of
quarantine and the you know one of the
things that came up that i thought was
interesting during this time was when
they were trying to figure out where
hot spots were one of the things they
were doing is testing sewage lines like
coming out of dormitories and colleges
and then they then they would know where
to start testing but obviously these
kind of sensors can start getting built
into built into infrastructure of cities
and start finding diseases before they
they really
blow up the way they have um but i'd
love to hear what has have these kind of
things happened in history and do you
see them happening in the future
i was just going to talk about sentinel
chickens very quickly yeah well so that
i mean there are low-tech ways of doing
that too i'm one of one of my favorite
um examples is sentinel chickens which
uh the
los angeles for example maintains a
flock of chickens outside the city um
and watches to see if they uh develop
west nile um virus and
and if so then that is a warning that
the muskie 2 with west nile virus has
made it to southern california and
they must respond so the this idea of
the sentinel is is you know can be low
tech as well as
sewage monitoring well thank you guys so
much this was fantastic and thank you
all for coming we really appreciate it
thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you